- All right, are we getting started?
Are we ready?
I'm just gonna say yes.
Hey everyone, if we can have
the cast and the creative,
come on screen, of all the MEZA shows,
so we can applaud you.
(Ashley cheering)
Thanks for joining us.
If you can just, when you come on,
if you can just say your name
and the show you were a part of.
If you were obviously
part of more than one
this season as well.
Let's start with you, Tavia.
- My name is Tavia Hunt,
and I was a part of "Blessings".
And I read stage directions
for "Daughters of the Confederacy".
- I'm Maal.
I was a part of "Blessings" as you saw.
- My name is Tyler Cruz.
I read stage directions for "Blessings",
and I played Alexandra in
"Daughters of the Confederacy".
- Hi, my name's Nome.
I was Baraka in "Blessings", yes.
- Alexandra.
- Oh, hi, I'm Alexandra.
And I was a part of "Blessings".
- Tyler?
- I went.
- Oh, sorry.
Johnny.
- Hi, I'm Johnny.
I was a part of "Daughters
of the Confederacy".
I played William Warpole Merryweather.
- Hi, all, I'm Anula.
I read for Private Betts
in "Where Pathways Meet" by a.k. payne.
It's so good to be here.
- Seun.
- Hey, hi, I'm Seun.
I played Dwight in "Where
Pathways Meet" by a.k. payne.
- And then let's hear from our
directors and our tech team.
Edmond, are you here?
We want to say thank
you, too if you're here.
- Hi, so I'm Edmond.
And I stage managed all three
of the readings for summer cabs.
- Woo.
- Hi, I'm Alex.
I directed "Blessings",
and I'm one of the co-artistic directors
of the summer cabaret.
- Hi, I'm Christopher Betts.
I'm one of the co-artistic
directors of the summer cabaret.
I directed "Daughters of the Confederacy"
and "Where Pathways Meet"
- I'm Liam, and I designed
the sound for the season.
- And Abigail, I think
you're the last one.
- Yes, hi, I'm sorry.
I'm Abigail.
I am the one of the actors
for a.k. payne's play
"Where Pathways Meet"
as well as Angie Bridgette Jones's
"Daughters of the Confederacy."
- Great, thank you so much, everyone.
Congratulations on an
amazing MEZA summer season.
You all worked so hard.
Oh, we have a guest.
Hey, a.k.
You just want to introduce yourself
and your name and the play.
- Hi, yeah, I'm a.k. payne.
I wrote "Where Pathways Meet".
- Amazing.
I was just saying thank you everyone.
And congratulations to the cast.
And thank you to the audience
for sticking with us.
We really appreciate it.
I'm Ashley Thomas.
I'm the co-moderator,
along with our lovely,
she's to the side of me, but Faith Zamble,
our other wonderful co-moderator.
So the way this is gonna work is
we're gonna ask some questions.
We're gonna talk to the
cast and the creative,
and then we'll open it up for Q&A.
So you'll have a chance
to also ask everyone questions as well.
And we just want to have a good time
and celebrate this evening.
So we're gonna kick it off.
We'd like to thank one of our sponsors,
the Yale Center for Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration.
They sent in some questions,
which is really exciting.
And we'll kick it off with them.
- Thanks so much, Ashley,
for that introduction.
Hello everyone.
Thank you all for coming again.
And thank you all who are on this panel.
I'm really excited to talk to you.
So the first question is pretty broad.
So you can answer it however you want.
But it felt important to acknowledge
the material conditions like the fact
that we're in a pandemic
and the fight for black
lives is continuing
in the streets right now.
And so one of the things
that I wanted to ask is
how did the creation of this work shift
because of those external conditions?
Do you feel like you were freer
to explore questions of race
and identity, or more limited?
This is a super general
question to get started,
but I guess what I'm really asking is
how did these events shape your process
as you were making this work?
- That's a tricky one to answer,
but I think for me,
especially working on this one,
which was clearly in response
to like a very specific
event, but also many
events that are similar.
I think coming into it, it felt like
in my experience, it
felt like myself along
with the other actors and
like all the creative team,
we were like speaking the same language.
And like, I felt like it actually was like
very aligning and like very unifying,
especially being in a
cast that was like made up
of entirely like black women pretty much.
And like, I think so.
Yeah, in my experience I found
it like very like grounding.
And yeah, it felt like we were sort of all
on the same page in terms of like,
not in terms of like our healing
and like our activism or even
really like our understanding
or like processing of what is going on,
but certainly like in
holding space for one another
and like in allowing for
whatever needed to come up.
And that felt very new and like unique
to my creative process, at least.
I don't know if that answers the question.
- Yeah, something that was
incredibly resonant for me
was there are specific lines
and text in a.k.'s play
that metaphorically refer to things
that happen in our history.
I think Minnie has a line.
And Abigail, if you could correct me,
where they say, where she says,
she lists names of people that have been
killed and lost their lives, you know,
at the hands of police
brutality or whoever.
But, you know, that was
incredibly resonant for me
because I think that, you know,
that was something that
was very race specific,
and it didn't matter what
time we were talking about it.
You know, it was something
that was very real for us
on the moon in "Where the Pathways Meet".
And, you know, there are
other references, too,
that a.k. has that refer to things
that happen on planet Earth,
but there are small
metaphorical things in the play
that, you know, really resonated with me
and gave me just a great
point of connection.
- Let's hear from maybe
one more before we move on.
- I think in a lot of ways
I've been thinking a lot about like how
this particular moment
shapes, like the work
that a lot of black writers are doing
and how like the struggle
has always continued
and the way in which like
black life has been a target
for so much violence is
like not a new thing.
But I think that in this time
I'm really grateful for this sort of space
to talk about it in a
global like broader sense,
and the way in which
like there seems to be
a collective movement to like
fight and hear black voices
in a way that like feels
different than past times,
at least to me.
And I think for me that gave me space
as I was revising "Where
Pathways Meet" for this
to revise in a way that was
reflective of that space,
if that makes sense.
And with more grace because of that space.
But yeah, I do think
that there's something
about like a continuous
struggle that like is important
to acknowledge that like the
work is ongoing and not new.
- Thank you for that.
So just a reminder,
we're gonna ask questions,
and then we'll open it up for
questions from the audience
through the Q&A function.
So thank you so much,
everyone, for being with us.
The next question that came from the
Yale Center for Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration is
what do you imagine the
afterlives of these works?
I know this isn't traditional
theater, this is Zoom theater.
I joke and say, "Now we
go to Zoom University."
But how do you all imagine
these works existing
and how do you imagine
yourself participating
in theater works that
exist in this digital space
that we're in right now?
- I think that for me, I loved
all three plays so deeply
that working on them through Zoom.
It was so funny because I
know when I was directing,
I kept pushing them to the
limit of what Zoom can be
and trying to embrace what Zoom can be.
And it really, really made me hanker for,
to like put the shows up on their feet.
I think, especially in Angie's play,
there's so much physical
comedy in that play.
And I think that a lot of
humor was able to be found
because we could not be physical,
and we had to do things through a camera.
And like, sort of leaning into that.
The medium really worked for that play,
but there was still a hunger.
I still have a hunger
to see all three of these
plays up on their feet,
and to work on these
because I think that they're
all incredibly theatrical.
And they demand to be theatricalized.
And you know, that is not what Zoom is.
So when I have worked,
when I come across work the
demands to be theatricalized,
that makes me want to put it on a stage.
So while I feel like we
reached what we could
through this medium, given this medium
and given the current state of our world,
it made me very hungry
to see these productions
have a full, these plays have a full life
with full production
and tech and costumes.
I also just like all of that stuff.
I'm like give me the
set, give me the budget,
give me all of that.
So, of course I want to see it like that,
but I think that these three
plays in general demand that.
- So if no one else has
anything that they want to add.
Although you can feel
free to stop me if you do,
I'm gonna move us to the next question.
Which sort of relates to the
one that came before which is
what has the experience
of working on Zoom,
working in these interesting times,
taught you about theater making
that perhaps you would want to
take with you going forward?
And how do you think
it will affect the way
that you approach work in the future?
And maybe there's nothing.
And what you've learned
is that you hate Zoom,
which is also an acceptable answer.
- I think that Zoom really
helped push my imagination.
You know, creating the
world of the play in,
you know, your tight space and imagining
that you're talking to this
person that's, you know,
supposed to be right in front of you,
even though you're
looking at the green dot,
like for me, I really had to set the space
and also kind of, you know,
take time to just know
where I am in the world of the play.
And really, really focus
on what is happening
outside of this small
box that is affecting me.
At first, it was very hard,
like it was difficult.
I did not like it at all,
but you know, over time I
started to kind of like,
you know, for lack of a
better word experiment,
you know, with what I
could create around me
and how those things could affect me.
You know, especially in a.k.'s play
where there's so many things
that happen in front of us,
like the magic and, you know,
the hammer being created
and the rocks, the stones turning into
whatever they were
turning into and the rain.
It just forced me to
really use my imagination
in ways that I don't think
I've ever done before on stage,
because it usually happens
right there in front of you,
whether it's with lights or
sound or anything like that.
- Yeah, and to add onto what Seun said
is that I think an
interesting thing about Zoom
is that there's no excuses.
Like, there's no budget,
there's no nothing.
You just have an opportunity
to be able to be like,
if I want to put up a black play
and I want to make it as
black as I want, you know,
this medium is a perfect
medium for you to do it.
It's definitely made
it a lot easier for me
as a performer and as a
writer to kind of be like,
I just want to put something up.
And I could just call
up some of my friends
and be like, "Hey, can you read this?
"And can we just do like
"a little Zoom production real quick?"
And there we go, we have a
play in a matter of seconds.
And so I think that this
medium really does open doors,
if you decide tomorrow that you want
to start writing your heart out
and that you want to put up some stuff,
you can have your mom be
an actor, and it'll work.
It'll work.
So I think that, it's exhausting.
Zoom fatigue is a thing,
it's very exhausting.
But I think it's worth it in the long run.
- I also think that Zoom is interesting
because you obviously don't
have one of the elements
that's pretty critical to live theater,
which is like an audience.
But like an audience that
like you are breathing
the same air and within the same space.
But I think in my limited
experience with Zoom theater,
it's like really made me reaffirm
and like reconnect with like
my personal like process
and like preparation and
also like my engagement
with my scene partner.
So that I'm not like
relying on like validation
that I might receive
from like people laughing
or like, or whatever it is.
And like, obviously that's great.
And like, I said something
funny, but I think like.
I don't know, there's something
really like wonderful,
and I think also to like, Abigail's point
something that's really
freeing about just like
being in this space where there isn't
either the validation or like
if you perceive it as judgment
or like, or whatever it is.
And so it feels like a little bit,
like you can like cut it up more,
and like, that's really strange.
And I think it's also sort
of made me think a lot
about like how I want to engage in my work
like once I'm back in the studio
and like back with my peers
and like back in an audience
and like, what can I,
what from that release
and like that freedom,
can I hang on to so that
I'm no longer feeling
like I'm having to like,
rely on sort of, for me,
sometimes it is like that,
like validation or that, yeah,
that like energy from an audience.
- And I'll say, too, honestly,
Zoom acting is really hard.
I think it's completely different
than what we're trained to do.
Like we kind of have to
go against everything
that we're taught as actors.
But the thing that I actually
do appreciate about Zoom
is like, it kind of goes
back to the basics of,
for me, I realized it's like an incredible
act of like faith and trust
because all we really have
are the playwright's words.
So for me, like going
through this process,
I was like, okay, if I just
trust the playwright's words.
And because I don't have the stimulation
that I would have in a live theater space,
like trusting the words
that I have in front of me,
trusting my own imagination,
trusting my company,
even though we're not
connected in the same ways
that we would be in a live setting.
I feel like there is
something about Zoom acting
that does bring it back to the basics
of relying on the language,
relying on the text
to give me everything that I need.
And kind of simplifying, which
I actually do appreciate.
- Just to say something
about what Alex just said.
That's what I'm really excited
to explore in the future
is because when you're on here,
you have to find a
different way to connect.
And what you just said
about the language is like,
how you say something is your
only form of connecting you,
is the only way they're gonna receive
anything from you, you know what I mean?
Because when you're doing a Zoom play,
a lot of the times you have to go
back and forth between a script.
So how many times do you
actually have the opportunity
to look at the person?
That usually comes a bit after.
There's a lot of technicality that comes
to doing stuff on here.
And so I think bringing
it back down to language.
And then once all of this is over
having to come back in
person with somebody,
you literally had to expand
your notion of connection.
You don't have body.
You don't have these other things.
So I think it'll, for a lot of us,
when we get back in person with people,
because now we can't just, you know,
punk out and rely on five other things.
You know, we've been
through that storm already.
We can do something else now.
- Thank you so much Ciara.
I think that's a perfect place
to wrap up this question.
And I just want to
welcome you to the call.
Would you mind introducing yourself?
We have Angie Jones on the call.
And I think we have Anthony
Brown also logged in.
So if you wouldn't mind just waving,
saying your name, the play
you were associated with
and we'll move onto the next question.
- Okay, I can go.
Hello, hi.
Excuse my tardiness, my CPT.
My name is Angie Bridgette Jones.
I am the playwright of
"Daughters of the Confederacy".
I am also a Capricorn
and a house Raven claw.
So hope that helps.
- Hi everybody, I'm Anthony.
I play Jackson in "Where
Pathways Meet" by a.k.,
directed by Christopher.
Yeah, glad to be here.
Sorry I'm late, sorry
I'm late, wifi issues.
- And then Ciara.
I'm not sure what character you played.
- Sorry, all right, so I'm Ciara.
Was in "Daughters of the Confederacy",
and I played Elizabeth Merryweather.
- Thank you all so much.
So, Alexandra, your point about not being
connected with people leads
me to my next question.
Dealing with connectedness,
being so tuned in all the time.
You're tuned in to Zoom
rehearsal, day in, day out.
You're looking at your
computer for the script
and that inadvertently may
lead you to looking at the news
and then checking social media.
So how did you all protect yourselves,
your physical and mental
health, during these pandemics?
You know, as in all mediums.
And I say we were living
in three pandemics
if your a black woman, you know?
So how did you really protect yourself
during these stressful times?
- Wait, the question was,
how do we protect ourselves during-
- During the rehearsal period, how did you
just protect your physical
and mental health?
- I would like to say laughing for myself.
Because if I don't laugh at
something, why am I here?
Just laughing and trying
to find a little bit of joy
and poking fun at this
thing through the computer.
Like there was this one really fun moment
where Abigail has to pop back on screen
with something in her hand.
And that was just the highlight of my week
because we all started
popping back to the screen
during rehearsal with like hot sauce,
a freaking roller rack.
Just stupid, just something,
God, give me something.
So, laughter, yeah.
- Well I've been taking use
of Yale Health's counseling and therapy.
So that's what I've
been doing a once a week
to just protect myself,
getting it all out once a week
and trying to, you know,
apply it to my life,
you know, apply it to the craft
and just move through this
transitional period with ease.
So that's what's been helping me lately.
- I don't know if my answer will,
I don't know if it answers you directly,
but I feel like I haven't
been protected in a sense
of like, what am I doing
to take care of myself?
And it's felt more of,
it just feels like an
ongoing continuous period of
growth and change and
confronting a lot about myself
and where I'm at in life.
And you know, so it kind of
feels like just standing,
I don't know, in front
of like a massive wave
that feels like what 2020 is right now.
But kind of connecting that to Zoom,
when it had started kind of
like what Seun mentioned,
it was really hard.
But couple of months in,
I'm beginning to accept,
I don't know this big advantage
of it, which is, sorry.
The reality of things is if you know,
I need to leave the country soon.
But I can still continue
working with people that I know,
people that I've trained with.
And that's a nice reminder.
And it's also a reminder of responsibility
that you aren't disconnected
at any given point
from your community,
from people that you can
take support comfort from,
as hard as it may be
to reach out for that.
So yes, Zoom is kinda
like a double-edged sword.
Like, you can't get away from it,
but also there's so much
that you can do with it
at any given point.
I don't know how that relates
to protecting oneself.
I think I'm still figuring that one out.
- Something that's also been, you know,
I mean, the pandemic has been horrible.
Y'all better be wearing your masks,
but it's been
good for me in the sense that like
I can't work towards ambition anymore.
And I can only work towards
like personal internal growth.
'Cause I mean, things
are shut down right now.
Like I can't be ambitious and say,
"Oh, I'm gonna go make these connections,
"and you know, go out there
and audition for this thing."
In a way it's still happening,
but it's given me a lot
of time to just like
reflect and think about, you
know, the type of person I am,
the people don't want
to surround myself with.
And that in a way has given me room
to actually just like grow,
sans the acting ambition part of it.
And I think that's been
really helpful for me.
I can honestly say that like this summer
has changed me a lot,
only because of the fact
that I've given myself that
time to actually reflect
and find that personal growth.
It's been healing.
- I'll say for me,
y'all it's hard, it is so hard.
But something recently
that has been really
life changing in a way is
me connecting to this idea
of like self compassion and
honoring however I feel,
unapologetically and also honoring
and expressing what it is that I need,
not only for myself,
but from other people.
So if that means there's a moment
where I need to prioritize black joy,
if I need to have a moment
of stillness or silence,
if I need to like dance or, you know,
having things around me that
support whatever I'm feeling
and to honor it first and foremost.
Without apology, without guilt or shame.
And then also like having
a sense of community,
'cause I think that's been
one of the hardest parts
is all of the ways I think
I'm used to coping with certain things,
have to deal with
relating to other people.
And now that that's kind of been removed,
how do I replace that feeling of community
which is so important to me,
through like other mediums?
So, you know, like doing free yoga classes
or therapy and checking in
with people that I love,
and, you know, whatever
I could possibly do
just honoring however I feel
and what I need in that moment.
And then going from there.
- Thank you so much for that.
This question is gonna be the last one
before we open up to the Q&A.
I'm gonna switch tacks a little bit
and I wanted to ask you all,
because so many of these
plays deal with freedom
and what it means to live a
good life or a happy life.
And all of the things that
sometimes stand in the way
of black people being able to access
those ways of being in the world.
I wanted to ask you all,
what does freedom look
like for you as performers,
as directors, writers,
creatives, stage managers?
Which could mean,
what does freedom look like
in your industry specifically?
Or what freedom looks
like for you personally?
But yeah, I would just
love to hear from you all,
like what is the world
that you are imagining?
- Freedom look like, looks like visually,
I see more Viola Davises on stage.
I see more,
I see more people with different accents,
different languages,
different skin tone, different body types.
That is not the
stereotypical Hollywood look
on stage, on film.
I see black playwrights on a daily
bringing stuff up.
I see black directors.
I see people of color everywhere.
Like in my mind, it's
like that kind of freedom
to know that like I can be the actor
that goes out into the world and knows
that somebody is going to
want my body as a performer,
period, is what I see
as like a free liberating
actor's life, you know?
- I think, oh-
- Everybody was ready to answer
that one, go ahead, Tavia.
- I think for me something
that I found really freeing
about this play that I just worked on
and something that I would love
to see expressed more fully
is just like putting a name to a thing.
Like, I feel like just like, I don't know,
like with all of these plays, like we're,
we're like naming these things
that are often so like
hidden or like coveted
or they're like really
softened or they're,
they're shared like hyperbolically,
or it's like things that we
are like as black people,
and especially as black women,
are meant to express or art
can socialize to express,
you know, shame about.
And like, I find it like,
so freeing to just be able to
like put a name to the thing
and to say like, this is what's happening.
And like that's incredibly
like affirming and like
liberating and like exciting.
And so, yeah, just to be
able to like boldly stand
in like our truths as black Americans
and definitely as black women.
That's what comes to mind for me.
- I think being able to
survive and create art,
like on our own terms.
When I say our, I mean
like all the different ways
that black diaspora exists
and shows up without
necessarily being limited
based on capitalism and based on the way
that capitalism manipulates our stories
and like makes us have to perform
for white gaze and spectatorship.
So yeah, that's what clicked for me.
And then I think a part of that is form
and how we can undo form, as
a writer and as playwrights
thinking about how we can
find our own structures
that like we've known
for a long time that,
yeah, that have been
silenced and erased from us
in a lot of the colonial histories.
- Something that feels freeing to me is
the border between art
forms kind of going away.
To tag onto the last
question is like some,
a way that I've found a lot of self care
is like by investing
in other black artists,
Michaela Coel, Anisa Reyes,
and like all of the people
who are where I want to be.
And something I really
appreciate about them
is that the policing that other people do
or try to place upon
them has not stopped them
from moving in the world.
And that's something
that I get policed a lot.
So I'm very, so freedom for me looks like
I can't stop the policing from happening,
but I can at least stop myself
from being affected by it.
And just being able to
like, not just be an actor,
but to also be able to
write, to direct, to produce
and to find like a home in
all of those mediums fluidly.
- Y'all are so poetic.
'Cause like as soon as I heard
the question, I was like,
"Oh, McDonald's and 'Bug's Life'.
"That's what freedom looks like to me."
Like I specifically, on a serious note,
I think freedom really just
looks like being enabled
to do things without anyone
asking you to explain it.
Like honestly, like I
get really bogged down
specifically in the realms of like
the pressures of institutions
and white supremacy
of being told over and over
again, what are you doing?
And I'm like, I was doing the same thing
I was doing every day, but it's because,
it's weird, because I
think in the realm of like
yeah, that we all are in, they're like,
"Oh, I came in here doing the
weird quirky black girl shit
"that everyone said that I
was supposed to be doing."
And then as soon as I get
here, everyone's asked me like,
"Why are you doing that
weird black girl that?"
well, y'all told me to do the thing
that y'all told me to do at the school.
So I guess like the
freedom that I look like
as being able to do whatever I want to do
without anyone asking me to do,
I mean like God bless the soul.
Kind of like a Kanye situation where like
I get to do whatever I want.
And the realms of like specifically
not being asked and to do,
or being asked consistently
of like what this is.
It's like, you can Google it.
Everyone has like the same
amount of information,
but I feel like as well, you know,
like the McDonald's and
"Bug's Life" situation.
Just being able to do whatever I want
without anyone asking me how
to do it or why I'm doing it.
- I think that freedom
for me as a director
is theaters really moving towards wanting
to uplift the stories of black voices
without posturing and being more concerned
with the monetization of black stories
and seeing how valuable
that is in their season.
And I think that that
starts with, you know,
if these theaters want to
accept us and invite us in,
and then, you know, you
sit in these meetings,
they're like, I don't
understand what's going on.
Of course you don't
And not having to go through that barrier
of having to explain,
"Well, in black culture, this means this.
"And the black people in the audience
"are gonna understand this."
I think that by having to educate
and prove in a way having to prove
and justify blackness to white people
is like extremely violent.
And I think that that happens very often.
And I think that if these institutions
aren't gonna give the
latitude for black people
to use their voices as
vocally as they can.
And the only way that black
people can give their voices
as vocally as they can
is if it's as far away
from its proximity to
whiteness as possible.
So of course, you know,
there are going to be things
that white people don't understand
that are going on in these black plays.
I think institutions,
I know institutions
have to let go of that.
And that's when the real
beginnings of things
are going to start to happen.
But that is still policing.
Coming in and making, having
to explain to someone,
having to explain to a white person
why this moment matters
or what this means,
because that institution
is who is employing you,
that is policing.
And if you are really about your EDI,
if you're really about the
work that you're doing,
if you're really about
uplifting these stories,
then go out of the room and let it happen.
Because it's not going to happen.
Your presence is not gonna contribute
in a wholly global way to
the uplifting of black voices
in the way that I think that
a lot of institutions assume,
based off of pedagogy, that it will.
- Wow, thanks, y'all, I'm blown away.
I moved to tears.
And you're right, I love tater tots.
You know, it's just something about them.
So there's freedom in that.
But I don't think my
nutritionist would approve
of me just eating tater tots.
Such a complicated life
we have in present day.
Thank you all so much for your time.
I invite the audience to
please type your questions
on the Q&A function.
We have one already.
So I'm gonna start it off
with that from Nicole Nelson.
Thank you for your question.
But in the meantime,
feel free to just use the Q&A function
to type your question,
and then we'll answer it.
So Nicole Nelson asked, this
is for a.k. payne's play
"Where Pathways Meet".
Did you create this play as a way
for the promises of the
civil rights movement
to intersect with the space race
between the U.S. and the Soviet Union
so that your African-American characters
could benefit from both events
as acts of black liberation?
Well, Nicole, I love
(indistinct), thank you.
- So yeah, one of the big
things I love about playwriting
is that there's like so
many different things
that are added onto it,
like when you're creating.
So like, yeah, I didn't think of this
when I was writing this.
And I think that, like,
it's really exciting
that that's a take that you have for it.
And I think that that's relevant
to the sort of storytelling
that I was interested in,
of just like how we imagine
freedom for ourselves
and how we have been a
part of these histories.
Yeah, so thank you for that question.
And I think that there's
a lot of different,
I think that "Where
Pathways Meet" is a piece
that I'm actively asking
questions about all the time.
'Cause I mean, there's so
many different metaphors
and it trafficked so much in metaphors,
so there's a lot of things that I think
can exist within it and exist,
yeah, in tandem with it.
So, thank you.
- Okay, so we have a question
from Joanie Banks-Hunt.
Thank you for this question, Joanie.
And they would like to know,
how does it feel to be
free to express who you are
as a vibrant, vibrant picture
of black love for our culture?
And maybe an additional
question to tack on to that is,
do you feel free?
And if you do, how does that feel?
And if you don't, how does that feel?
- I mean, when I do
these works, I feel free.
I know that like a big
thing for me this summer
was to like really be
able to immerse myself
in black work and just live in it.
Though there's some times
we would finish rehearsal
and there's this, when
you shut your computer
and you no longer have
the people around you,
that lingering feeling that
you have after a rehearsal
where things have set and marinated
and you are in this soup of
stuff together, it's just like,
you're in it by yourself.
And it has, like you sometimes
I have to take some time
to just, I don't know,
like take a walk or listen
to some Sade or something
so that I could just, you know.
Because it becomes part of you.
A part of me is Minnie.
A part of me is Rosina, right?
There's a part of me that
is all these characters.
they can't leave you in a way,
but if you want to like really
immerse yourself in the work,
if you really want to
soak in it, you know,
you take the time that you have to just,
I am with, I'm with
the playwright's words.
And I am the actor trying to just marinate
in this life that I'm living in.
Even if I have to like close
the computer afterwards
and like be by myself.
It hurts, but it also is
like fulfilling in a way.
If that answered the question.
- We're gonna move on just because
y'all are coming up with
beautiful questions.
So, thank you.
Katherine Chihi, thank you
so much, Katherine Chihi.
Katherine Chihi asks,
could the two playwrights on the call,
a.k. and Angie mention
a few of the writers
who have inspired their plays?
Do you two identify
yourselves in these works,
do they identify themselves in these works
as part of a tradition of black writers
whom they admire?
And Gloria Majule, who wrote
"Blessings" is not on the call,
unfortunately, but she's
here with us in spirit.
But our two lovely
playwrights who are here,
if you wouldn't mind answering.
So basically do you identify
and do you see yourself a part
of a tradition of black writers?
- Yeah, so definitely I think
for this particular piece,
I really look to like,
so I'm no B.C. Phillip,
she's a poet who I love.
And so Christina Sharpe as well,
Robin D. G. Kelly.
I have a list in the beginning of the play
that I'm reading right now.
And also some musicians.
So like Sun Ra, Nina Simone, and Prince.
And Minnie Evans, who is a visual artist.
I think that I really
try to locate my work
and my storytelling in like
the black radical tradition.
'Cause I feel like that, there's
a lot of potential in there
to imagine new worlds and
new land for ourselves.
And yeah, but thank you for that question.
- A question from Madame, we love that.
I definitely do think
I am in the tradition
of the black arts movement
that was started in the seventies.
A lot of my family members
are like black intellectuals and artists.
So they were basically like
transplants of that movement.
So growing up, I've definitely heard a lot
of like the conversations
of what it was like
to be in that movement in
terms of black liberation,
but also in terms of like
freedom of expression
and humor and comedy,
not necessarily in
terms of like the pathos
of what it is to be a part of black life,
but what is it to be happy?
And so I think the writings
that I actually look to a lot
for, at least for "Daughters
of the Confederacy",
wasn't really a lot from playwrights,
it was actually from a lot
of like 1970s, 80s, 90s,
like black comedy comedians.
Like I was listening to
a lot of Richard Pryor.
Listening to a lot of like
older Dave Chappelle and Chris Rock.
And I think a lot of the
times we don't really consider
standup comedians as writers
because we don't really see
them in the writing process.
We're usually watching
them in like the stamina
of what it is to put on performance.
But I think for me,
listening, and then also
just hearing the words
of what these artists were saying
was actually very important
of like a lot of the text
that was actually being spoken to you.
Of like the delivery, of
the rhythm and the timing.
And also just like,
what are they saying
in terms of the pathos?
I think one part in the
rehearsal process we had, like,
I just sent everyone like a
list of like things that like,
I loved in terms of black comedy.
Like I showed them like Leslie Jones
and like, like more like Richard Pryor.
And I said, and I think we
were having that conversation
of what it is to deal with trauma
and how do we laugh at it?
And I was like,
"Oh, we just have to listen
to like Richard Pryor's bit
"about how he lit himself on
fire freebasing on cocaine."
Like, I heard that in high
school and I was like,
"This is the funniest thing
I've ever heard in my life."
But it was also very, very tragic
at like the very minimal
part of his whole life.
So I guess like a lot of the things
that I'm very invested in have always been
in the realms of comedy.
Like I definitely was influenced
by George C. Wolfe, "The Colored Museum".
A lot of like black writers
who may not like be known
in terms of like the white
consciousness, if you will.
But I definitely do think that those,
and also listening to like family members
and listening to like
so many intricate parts
of like black life has
definitely influenced
like "Daughters", in retrospect.
And also growing up in
the South, that's fun.
- I love both of these answers.
And Angie specifically,
I think that the conversation
about comedy and blackness
really needs to be at the forefront
of people's consciousness,
because I think there's
something really Greek
about the extremes of comedy and tragedy
that just coalesce to form
a lot of what black life is in America.
And shout out to a.k.'s reading list
because I'm working through it right now.
And it is changing a lot
of my thought processes.
So we have a question
from anonymous attendee.
And they would like to hear
from the playwrights again.
Sorry, y'all.
And they're asking,
after seeing your work
performed in this way, via Zoom,
are there any aspects of your work
that stood out or rang differently
than you had originally expected?
- I can go.
It's funny, 'cause like
earlier this morning today
I was watching like these Zoom
table reads of like TV shows.
Like they'll just all come together
and do like table reads
of like old episodes.
So I was watching one for "Community".
And it was so funny
'cause like the episode
that they were doing was like
an episode I've seen before.
But I think it was so hilarious
because I was so dying in
my kitchen listening to it
because I was just literally
hearing like the writing
and the joke writing and like the delivery
of the timing of the actors.
And even without like
the visual element of
like seeing them doing it in the episode
still made it for me.
And I think that's actually something
that I witnessed a within
the rehearsal space
with "Daughters" was like
hearing like the thing out loud.
Even if it was over Zoom
and letting the actors go
and letting like Christopher
take over the reins
of what that was.
I think it was like a very
enjoyable experience for me.
I don't particularly like
enjoy listening to my words.
I don't like listening
to my words out loud
specifically when it's being
read for the first time,
because it's always that journey of like,
"Okay, like we're gonna figure out
"like what world that we're in."
But I feel like immediately,
like when we started,
it was like the same kind
of like intensity high,
like just listening to like
this old "Community" episode.
Like I heard when I was in
high school to like now.
I'm like, "Oh, this is still like funny."
And I'm like, I hate listening
to like things I write like,
"Oh, that's a joke."
I was like, Oh, but this is great
because seeing them go even on Zoom
was still exciting for me, honestly.
I think that's just kind
of like the thing of,
you know, we're alone in our
houses majority of the time,
or at least like for me,
like I'm living by myself.
So like, like hearing
people like out loud,
like in the space that is
in mind feels more intimate
and it feels like more like,
Oh, like it's kind of
like still the same aspect
of not trying to put the
two mediums together,
like TV and like theater,
but it's like, "Oh,
you're in my living room."
And I feel kind of like invited
to like feeling that I'm there.
And with that, it makes
it even more, you know,
intimate in the same way
that I would be in theater
where I'm like,
y'all are like really
like this in front of me.
And then y'all,
I can literally see the
spit that y'all having
all the way through.
Like, so there's different
levels of intimacy
that I definitely notice
within this process
that I thought was actually
really exciting to see,
pandemic and all.
- Yeah, and I'll echo,
I think the intimacy thing
was a huge part for me.
'Cause I think there are a
lot of really quiet scenes,
especially between Minnie and Dwight
in this particular play where it, like,
there opened up something for me.
And seeing it on Zoom because
of the sort of closeness
that we were able to employ in that,
in that Abigail and Seun
were able to embody.
And I think that in, that too,
like I think that the core of theater
is imagining what isn't there of course.
And like imagine beyond.
And so in this particular
Zoom performance,
because we didn't have
like, everything is imagined
'cause we're just like
looking at each other.
I think that there was even more room
for the imagination in that,
which I think was really
freeing in terms of like,
just being able to just
leave everything open.
Like what does freedom mean to you?
And that that being able to change
according to who's watching it
and bearing witness in a new way.
- Thank you.
We have comments left.
We're gonna read them aloud
because we love affirmation.
So we have a comment
from Dr. James Perlotto,
who's a Yale Summer Cabaret board member.
So thank you so much for your support.
James said Zoom productions
definitely feel like theater, not film.
Yet the focus on such close up visions
of the performers gives even
more than a front row seat
to subtle expressions
and nuances of acting.
It is an interesting
hybrid of stage and video.
Thanks for the great
performances to each of you.
Dr. Jim Perlotto.
Thank you so much for that comment.
Yeah, it's a weird liminal space to be in,
you know, but we're doing the best we can.
We're making it work.
- So this next comment made me laugh.
And I see, perhaps,
anonymous cause these
are my exact thoughts.
But this person said,
"I am so very proud of all of you.
"Detective playwright,
"did you know that the officer was guilty?
"Mama, thank you for getting justice.
"Next time, pay someone else to do it."
Advice to take to the bank.
- Amazing.
Thank you all so much.
I guess I have one question
for Liam and Edmond.
Thank you so much for
rocking with us on this call.
And thank you.
I guess, what was it like for you
making those technical decisions,
those design decisions,
or, you know, stage management decisions
to have them enter a certain
way or at a certain time
or coming in on a certain kind of music?
We always love hearing what it's like
to cook up on the back end.
- Liam, I'll let you take
this and then I'll answer it.
- Okay, cool.
It's really interesting
designing sound for Zoom is,
I'm just gonna take one
of my headphones off
because otherwise I
sound weird in my head.
It's really interesting
designing for Zoom.
All the kind of,
so many of the tricks you
get used to in live theater,
like, you know,
sounds coming from different spaces,
sounds kind of coming
in under like a speech
and supporting an actor's voice.
All of those things are like
totally thwarted by Zoom.
You know, you can't have multiple sounds
playing at the same time.
You can't have sound come
from different directions.
So you really have to
be very, very specific
and very kind of like essential
in the choices you make.
Which I think leads to a really,
I don't know, can lead to
some really interesting
ways of sonic storytelling.
So sometimes the process,
basically I had conversations
with Christopher and with Alex.
And we would talk about the
kind of sound needs for the show
and you know just the way
to kind of support that.
And to kind of like execute
decisions and tell the story
in usually like the
simplest and most concise
and often quickest way that we could
sonically to just try and like, you know,
to tell the story and to like aid
in the telling of the story.
But like as has been alluded to before,
like the text is really the carrier
of the piece in this format.
And so to really not
interfere with the text
or you know, to interfere
as little as possible.
- And I think on my end it
was definitely different.
So definitely a different experience.
About a solid 85 to 90% of the things
that I would normally do
doesn't exist in the
realm of Zoom theater.
So it was a lot of also
reinterrogating and re-examining
who I am in these
processes and in this space
when working with individuals,
which was really nice is
almost everyone that worked
on these shows this summer,
were someone that I had
already worked with.
So for me,
it was more of just
continuing that connection
with people that I have
already worked with
and engaged with.
And definitely filled a sense of community
and those things that we've
been missing since COVID started
in all of the craziness.
But it's definitely been nice to be able
to just be a part of
sitting back and listening
and watching and kind
of engaging in the text
like everyone has been saying.
'Cause I'm not spending all this time
figuring out when these
light cues are gonna happen
or when sound is going to happen
or how entrances and exits
or costume changes are gonna happen.
And I definitely feel like
over these last three weeks,
I've been so much more connected
and engaged with the conversations
that are happening in
the room and in the space
and what the text is actually saying
instead of having to kind
of be split focused on,
yes, I'm hearing this point,
'cause this is really great and creative,
but also how do I make sure
that this vision of the scene
comes together logistically?
Or have we asked these questions
of these different departments
or am I taking notes about these things?
And I was really able to sit
back and let the artists work.
And then also just sit back
and enjoy watching the artists work
in ways that I don't normally get to do
when I'm sitting behind a
table in the rehearsal room.
So that part was fun.
Definitely it was hard not
having personal connection time.
It's weird when we go on a break,
and normally I would walk around
and check in with people on breaks
and see how things are going
and talk about daily life,
stuff like that.
And instead on Zoom,
a break means everyone
turns their cameras off, mutes their mics
and walks away for 10 to 15 minutes.
And it's a much more disconnecting
than we're used to in the
actual rehearsal rooms.
But eventually I think
we'll figure out ways
to make sure that that community
aspect of it still stays.
- So one of the recent
comments that we got
is actually for you, Liam.
And it says that the church organ music
was powerful and eerie.
And I just want to just
give you a special shout out
for all of your work that you did,
especially when you were moving.
And say how grateful we are for you
and your arsenal of fire sounds.
Yeah.
- Lots of fire this season.
- What can we say?
We're trying to burn
everything to the ground.
And Edmond, I also wanted
to say thank you to you
for your sense of humor
and for your continuous wonderful emails
that tell us everything we
need to know the night before.
So if there are, since there
are no other questions,
I want to take this opportunity
to thank the MEZA sponsors
and the leadership team
for putting together
such an interesting and necessary season.
We love you,
and we're grateful for all of your work.
And we also of course
want to thank our audience
because without you,
there would be nothing.
We would just be in the abyss,
which we kind of already are.
So thank you everyone for coming.
And we hope that you have a good night.